do you think that Ryan's shirt is
problematic do you think it objectifies
women their water ladies are waterskiing
of all lifting each other up like MC
Escher's we should be in factory say it
again feminist shirt where they're all
lifting each other up above the water in
bikinis yes they're rewriting their
sexuality to lift each other up above
the patriarchy which is oh oh with smart
comments like that I think it's gonna be
a good episode this is every damn day in
the show where we talk about what the
Internet's talking about our first story
get ready for this the World Health
Organization has declared that gaming
disorder is an official diagnosis
condition and this is good because it'll
allow professional professionals to add
the wrong card to provide Jordan your
gamer what do you think it's well some
people are saying like 20 hours a week
is the addictive amount but like if
you're playing 20 hours you're like
that's like a noob well like you should
be playing way more if you want to be
better you should be playing until your
hands like stop working and then you go
to bed you're not exactly we work all
the time like we're always writing right
I'm always I don't know I was more of a
gamer in like high school so I could
only play for like six hours at a time
yeah
is anyone else here game one time I
played for like five hours straight and
my girlfriend was like I feel like maybe
you should consider not doing that is it
any different than being addicted to
your phone with social media and things
like that
I don't think it is ya know I once was
so addicted to candy crush that it would
be like you have to wait 24 hours so I
changed the time on my phone
[Laughter]
and my texts weren't coming in it really
I'm sorry it really messed up my life I
don't find I don't find them addictive
but I think that's because like the
rewards in those games aren't
interesting for me it's like points or
leveling up do you like any games do I
like any games at all one time I asked
because one time I invited you and
invited Natasha over to my apartment to
teach her pandemic a great collaborative
board game were you and your friends
together have to fight off the virus I
can't believe I can't believe she wasn't
into you explaining aboard a cool 45
minutes to explain the rule I truly I
would be like cold my turn does someone
else want to go for the weirdest thing
that anyone's ever been addicted to and
I don't mean to use that lightly or have
felt like you've started to become
addicted to what behavior everyone
Hannah can I say masturbation for a
while it's bad funny so real this is
good this is actually what I was gonna
say this is actually all just been an
intervention meaning this point it's
become an issue at work Anna that's
become an issue
how many bear for a break
you learn things that little man and we
installed a camera to watch them when we
were away and I got addicted to that
it's just so fun just likes it and then
they'll move that's like a real life
like digi pet that you got a dick I
couldn't feed it from there or walk it
was the cat game those popular recently
cats amore or something you know yeah I
would do make cats and all right captain
Morey to me sounds like that's some old
I know that no I'm saying what is what
are we talking about it's an app but I
still don't know what that is or like
what happened to the mean again yeah but
in case it's like an app where you take
care of cats right and like you give
them little gifts in the morgue cans of
tuna you put out like the next time you
check more neighborhood cats have come
to your yes the cats like that's what
which is a thing it's a thing like
something they figured out like
scientific we like cats give off like
something that people if the poop right
people get addicted to
yes cat ladies are addicted so basically
people playing video games
you're like the crazy cat ladies of
Technology here's another thing that
we're gonna do right now
[Music]
hello i'm jordan and once a week I'd
take a little more psychedelics than
usual and write in my journal these are
my thoughts
don't you hate having this conversation
at Cinnabun I'd like a synonym roll do
you mean a cinnamon roll kinda it's a
different roll but it means the same
thing this has been called fill in the
blank
I'm Ryan this is Ryan's fill in the
blank I have a nice paragraph here but
there's some holes in it so I need to
code you each person and get some parts
of speech I'll put them into the
paragraph and then I'll read back what
we wrote right sounds like a fun party
game you should let me know okay
well pop quiz here we go yes I need an
adjective funny funny okay Jordan I need
an emotion oh happy tena an adjective
scary scary that's a good one
Nate will you please give me an
adjective and a noun
okay smelly smelly and litter box litter
box I'm gonna need a verb walking and a
plural noun puppets puppets hi Hannah
I'm gonna need a female creator Natasha
one that's here and the answers Hannah
alright and I need Chris I needed to
name something you eat cheese cheese I
need you to give me an expletive
because I wanted to blank it
out it's kind of funny when they blank
it out but I want to keep it in that's
funny when they blink it out here I need
a plural noun plants and a really large
number a million and Nate I need an
annoying thing something that annoys you
Oh
when people try to get on the subway
before they've let people getting off
get off if that's too long let's say no
that's fine okay okay Chris I need you
to tell me what an adverb is and give me
one of those
Haseley hastily what is like a verb all
right give me a very exciting adjective
Oh
sprite oh I was gonna say sprightly I
think that's that works right no I'll go
with sprightly everybody okay you guys
ready to hear what we came up I love
working at my funny new job the people I
work with make me feel happy that's why
I've listed a few ways in which I'm
really annoyed with them honestly this
work environment while fun is super
stressful because most of you can't get
your together especially in your
scary personal lives I'm so sick and
smelly that I've got to play third
litter box to Jordan and Chris's
buddy-cop movie it makes me want to it
makes me want to walk off a cliff every
day with this why don't you puppets
just get married already
and don't get me started with Hannah I
have quickly put up with whatever weird
you smell Olli have been doing the
past you know what I'd like to put my
cheese in the work fridge - it's a
shared space it's a shared space Jake
keeps leaving his yogurt everywhere
we're going to get bugs but do you you
want bugs I don't think so in conclusion
you flowery plants I love you despite
your millions of flaws and people
getting on the subway who also want to
get off the subway when you're trying to
get off the subway
thanks for hastily playing this
sprightly game of Ryan's
fill-in-the-blank was the yogurts just a
true sentence good idea that's just the
thing I do right that I should stop
doing something somebody else go throw
that one anything in the fridge so don't
put anything in the fridge I don't use a
fridge we're allowed to put some stuff I
know but to say I put cheese in the
fridge I know those crisps is filling a
blank but that's so erroneous for them I
would have put my cheese in the in the
in the fridge I don't put anything in
fridge
Jesus delicious this was supposed to be
a fun party game I don't know what
happened I didn't mean to start an
argument
[Music]
you